il est une autre intelligence c'est
celle qui vient d'ailleurs celle qui
vient du ciel
les extraterrestres et les intéressent
affaire avait tout le monde les enfants
ou les adultes qui sont restés enfants
parmi ces adultes france roche
il y à un metteur en scène tout à fait
exceptionnelle steven spielberg dont on
connaît déjà les dents de la mer
rencontre du troisième type qui avait
commencé avec duels et qui en fait à
chacun de ses films a obtenu un succès
considérable succès de quantité le plus
grand public les plus grosses recettes
mais succès de qualité aussi
car la critique ne trouve rien à y
redire au contraire et spielberg
aujourd'hui sort un film qui s'appelle
hiti le thé les initiales pour
extraterrestres
je vous disais en début de journal que
ce film a droit à d'ores et déjà dans la
presse française huit pages dans
l'express de cette semaine la couverture
de vsd huit pages d'entretien dans le
point et marie françoise leclerc a donc
droit france roche à ce qu'on appelle
effectivement une couverture très fourni
et il a raison c'est pas simplement le
succès commercial
non mais quand même si gilbert guay est
un personnage extraordinaire parce que
quatre de ses films sont parmi les 10
meilleures recettes américaines et son
film qui a coûté 10 millions 6 de
dollars a déjà en six mois fait 200 fois
sa mise
et quand même quelqu'un qui s'il
retrouve des recettes pareil va les
chercher auprès d'un public dont ils ne
touchent le coeur très très profondément
car on dit qu en amérique certains
spectateurs sont allés voir le film 5 et
6 fois il n'y a que cette explication
pour donner un tellement grand nombre de
spectateurs dans un si peu de temps
alors naturellement comme steven
spielberg et le monsieur qui frappe
toujours et gagne le succès le
merchandising comme on dit c'est à dire
la commercialisation de son personnage
est allés bon train et on va voir
venus d'amérique à certain nombre de
choses par exemple vous avez ce petit
personnage là qui est fait à la main à
taïwan qui est fait paraît-il
d'acrylique et de coki de noisettes
écrasé bon hit i face et itil un peu
améliorée parce que quand même on sent
que pour le vendre à des enfants ont là
un petit peu embellie quartier vraiment
très laid le voyez
pense la laideur de haïti fait partie de
son charme
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles le
petit enfant dans le film elliott tombe
aussitôt amoureux amis en tous les cas
dit il c'est parce qu'ils tissent est
extra terrestre contrairement à ce qui
se faisait jusqu'ici n'est pas grand
démesurée et un peu effrayant une pauvre
petite chose pathétique vous avez vous
avez de sting qui est un extraterrestre
monstrueux et méchant qui est en ce
moment sur les écrans il ya eu la
ressortie des aliens qui était un
monstre est évocateur là c'est une façon
que les hommes ont peut-être de se
rassurer en se disant les ans qui
viennent des étoiles seront peut-être
comme nous pas trop fort alors pour
continuer sur l'exploitation commerciale
dont vous parliez il ya donc cette
petite poupée qui se vend d'ores et déjà
aux états unis et qui est en france
maintenant circulation vous avez un
diesel lice le disque livre une puis
vous avez le disque normal d'ailleurs il
y aura des versions disco également vous
avez le livre la novélisation comme on
dit du film et puis vous aurez des
calendriers des petites bêtes qui
avanceront en parlant vous aurez un jeu
de construction qui permettra de
construire un téléphone extra stellaire
et puis vous aurez également un album et
un certain nombre de jeux électroniques
naturellement il ya deux jeunes filles
deux enfants une joie presque une jeune
fille faisait 14 ans justine et vous
mathilde vous avez dix ans qui avait
déjà vu ce film
alors avant de parler parce qu'on va
avec france roche se faire une petite
rétrospective de la carrière de ce
steven spielberg avant d'en parler ça ne
vous choque pas du tout vous cette
exploitation commerciale comme on dit
d'un phénomène n'est pas du tout ça vous
semble normal et vous
quand j'ai vu le film j'ai toujours
tellement ça génial que je trouve ça
normal qu'ils d'être effet pour
politique et que les petites poupées
suivent plus alors parlons un peu de
beurre dans france roche une vision vous
et moi qu'il ya en effet un phénomène
s'est sans doute est absent du 2 mettant
en scène en fait deux hommes de cinéma
qui dans le monde ont toujours obtenu
l'accueil extraordinaire du grand public
c'est walt disney et c'est alfred
hitchcock et on peut très bien dire que
spielberg d'une certaine façon c'est
l'enfant que 19 et hitchcock non on peut
dire aussi de georges locas parce que
george lucas ça fait quand même la
guerre des étoiles je crois que ceux qui
ont gagné les ressorts de les records de
recettes sont les gens qui en effet
cherche un public qui est jeune jeunes
d'âge ou jeune dame ça c'est sûr alors
spielberg
on l'a suivi depuis duels et i7
intéressant et vous france de faire ce
qu'on peut appeler donc une
rétrospective de sa filmographie qui est
arrivé désormais haïti ce succès
triomphal
ces vieilles photos c'est le seul
document de tournage de fright un film
en 8 mm dirigé par steven spielberg à
saison avec des copains comme acteur
c'était l'histoire de savants qui ont
découvert d'étranges lueurs dans le ciel
depuis spielberg n'a jamais cessé de
janvier avec les planètes comme avec des
balles et le surnaturel et son royaume
il a inventé des démons par exemple dans
duel un camion étrange qui essayent
d'assassiner une voiture et son
conducteur
dans joe's un requin géant qui croque
nageurs pêcheurs et même bateau
qui des merveilles d'une soucoupe
volante musicale par exemple de
rencontres du troisième type
pour les secrets biblique mêler aux
mystères un cas dans les aventuriers de
l'arche perdue
ou ses films record de recettes d'un hit
i vous allez voir les deux enfants d'une
femme abandonnée par son mari chercher à
sauver un petit extra terrestres ans
perrine et fouillent leur garage afin de
découvrir des éléments qui permettront à
haïti de se fabriquer un téléphone
interstellaire mais pendant ce temps un
camion espions mystérieux tourne autour
de leur maison
enregistrant toutes leurs paroles est ce
le fbi s l'armée qui veut s'emparer du
petit extraterrestre pas plus gros qu'un
juin
gomis
huawei amis
action
com
on
quand spice boy
ouais